bonjour à nicollier bonjour monsieur
kadrige vous êtes candidate aux
élections municipales et communautaires
de mars 2020 vous présentez pour la
ville de fond saint denis à la tête d'un
mouvement et d'une liste peut-être qui
porte le même nom l'envol denise hien
pourquoi avez vous choisi d'être
candidate pour mars 2020 en fait j'ai
choisi effectivement donc je me présente
en tant que tête de liste pour le groupe
l'envol denise y ans et j'ai fait ce
choix en fait de me positionner pour les
municipales de fond saint denis en mars
2020 parce que j'ai fait un constat au
niveau de la commune qui est le suivant
je pense que au regard de la situation
de la commune où en fait on a beaucoup
de parcelles abandonnées la commune est
totalement abandonnée et un départ
massif des jeunes faute de moyens de
communication faute d'enjeu ou de
problématiques qui répondent à leurs
besoins
non seulement cela on a constaté qu'à
une baisse démographique qui semble en
tous les cas vertigineuse sur les
quelque dix dernières années tout cela
en fait me démontre que font ces noms ni
tend à disparaître et au regard de cela
mais c'est la photo qui selon vous ben
en fait ce qu'il faut savoir que pour
qu'une commune puisse vivre quand je
parle de vivre ce pas seulement de ces
quelques âmes
quand je parle de vivre c'est vivre de
manière économique vise de manière eux
de manière culturelle vivent de manière
culturelle
mais vivre et tout ce qui s'ensuit beau
qu'une commune puisse parvenir à cela il
faut qu'on puisse en tous les cas en
tant que élu en tant que conseil
municipal pour puisse répondre aux
enjeux qui permettent en tout les cas
d'éviter ce genre de situation ça n'a
pas été le cas de l'équipe sortante
selon vous aujourd'hui je reconnais avec
à sa tête henri romana aujourd'hui je
reconnais comme sur humana qui est le
maire son temps n'a pas été à la hauteur
de ces enjeux
et justement au lieu justement de
proposer des solutions qui permettent à
la commune de sortir de cet état
d'abandon au lieu d'un fer tout se nomme
qu'est ce qu'il a fait il a fait des
promesses mirobolantes
au contraire il a démoli un outil
économique qui est le gîte d'étape et
coca est l'unique gîte d'étape qui
existent en martinique
il a détruit dit vous c'est lui qui l'a
démoli sa joie qui a été fait et qui et
je dirai récent qui est mal en tous les
cas 2 août 2019 alors qu' il est en
place depuis 2014 d'accord vous vous
n'êtes pas d'accord sur cette action là
sur ce je ne suis pas d'accord sur cette
action pourquoi pas ce que font ces mini
présente des atouts de tourisme vert et
intel gîte devrait justement on aurait
dû le réhabiliter le réajuster le 6
étudiants tous les cas comment valoriser
cet outil plutôt que de le démolir on ce
n'est pas le choix qui a été fait par
monsieur romana le maire sortant et son
équipe
deuxièmement une chose que je reproche
en tous les cas monsieur roux mana et
qui fait que je et qui me permet en tous
les cas de dire que monsieur romana avec
son équipe n'a pas su répondre aux
enjeux de la commune
c'est la question de la bibliothèque
nous avions une bibliothèque municipale
havre saint denis et qu'on a t'il fait
il a décidé de mettre en place de cette
bibliothèque une oeuvre religieuse
certes il ya peut-être un besoin au
niveau de la commune mais la
transmission du savoir
je reste persuadé que c'est très bon
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez vous comme
propositions phares justement de votre
programme et qui ferait que font
saint-denis sortirait de cette spirale
que vous venez de décrire en tout cas
que vous vous estimez que les alors ce
que j'ai comme propositions phares en
tous les cas par le passé font saint
denis a été le grenier de leader on ne
cesse de le dire à l'époque de l'amiral
robert et je reste persuadé qu encore
aujourd'hui font saint denis peut-être
une commune pourvoyeuse en produits
agricoles et donc par rapport à cela ce
que je propose de faire justement c'est
de proposer une box foncière à la fois
publiques et privées mais plus basé sur
le principe de la sauter ou en fait le
principe de la sorte elles sont en
principe de coups de main où chaque
agriculteur n'est pas isolé ne le dirige
pas son exploitation tout seul dans son
futur les il ya du religieux alisation
sur les loyers totaux niveau humain
qu'au niveau technique qu'au niveau
matériel donc ça c'est une proposition
que nous faisons est l'une des
propositions aussi que nous faisons pour
pouvoir rpt en quelques mots le
territoire plus attractif c'est de créer
les berges denise
des berges aunisiennes qui vous répond
désormais à un tourisme balnéo vert
qu'est ce que vous appelez les berges de
l'hygiène alors en fait nous avons un
site qui est très remarquable à foncer
monique et le site de ce genre d'homme
qui est aujourd'hui saturée la plupart
du temps surtout en période de vacances
scolaires ou même à lapproche jeudi par
rapport à quelque chose de d'hydraulique
un site où il ya donc ces faits c'est le
lot c'est le long de la rivière du cab
est seul au long des différents cargos
qui existe à ménager aménageable
aménager ces espaces là puisque en fait
effectivement le touriste lambda ils
connaissent au journal parce qu'on parle
de soja dame mais in fine mais il ya
d'autres sites qui sont aussi roland
câble que c'est aux gendarmes qu on
pourrait aménager très bien merci annie
commis et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions une émission réalisée par
rodrigue calixte bonne journée merci
beaucoup